mais d'abord donc les enseignements du
baromètre au doxa mascaret du mois de
juin et pour commencer un gros plan sur
l'exécutif qui dévisse avec jérôme à
rabieh c'est un avertissement pour
l'exécutif au moment où les grandes
manoeuvres sont en cours pour trouver
des majorités qu'ils voteraient les
projets de loi au cas par cas le
président de la république perd six
points de popularité en un mois
questionné sur le fait de dire si
emmanuel macron est un bon président de
la république
seuls 38% des sondés répondent par
l'affirmative
un niveau de roger qu'il n'avait pas
atteint depuis plus d'un an
elisabeth bornes de son côté n'a pas la
chance de connaître l'état de grâce
traditionnelle après une nomination
la première ministre chute de 10 points
pour son second baromètre elle est une
bonne locataire de matignon pour
seulement 33 % des français interrogés
son prédécesseur jean castex n'avait
jamais atteint un plancher aussi bas en
matière de popularité
précision importante les sondés ont été
interrogés avant qu elisabeth bande soit
confirmé dans ses fonctions ce week-end
et qu'elle entame une nouvelle tournée
de négociations aujourd'hui c'était au
tour du chef de file des député es l'ère
olivier marleix kz2 l'a rencontré à la
sortie il confirmé la position dlr
évidemment n'était pas question de
quelques additions que ce soit mais
qu'on était là pour essayer de trouver
des solutions pour les français pour le
pays on va voir ça terme de texte sur
lequel je pense qu'on doit pouvoir
travailler ensemble la question du
pouvoir d'achat d'évidence à l'issue de
ces consultations l'exécutif devra
trancher pour constituer ce qu'ils
appellent un nouveau gouvernement
d'action une déclaration de politique
générale ou elisabeth bornes dévoilera
ses priorités est toujours prévue le 5
juillet à l'assemblée et le sis au sénat
pas sûr en revanche que cette
déclaration soit suivie d'un vote de
confiance signe d'une majorité tout
relatif qui rebat les cartes
et on analyse les résultats de ce
baromètre les leçons de juin avec mes
invités claire chartier bon bonjour
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste et
essayiste
gaël sliman le président de l'institut
de sondage au dos que ça bonjour et
bienvenue mathieu sous caire essayiste
auteur avec damien fleurot de 2022 la
flambée populiste publié aux éditions
plon laetitia copa éditorialiste
politique
avec moi comme chaque mardi et chaque
jeudi
on va commencer donc par l'exécutif gaël
sliman si on reprend concernant emmanuel
macron 38% d'opinions favorables -
6.6 rentre un peu dans le détail qui lui
maintient sa confiance font confiance
pardon est ce que c'est toujours une
france on va dire plutôt urbaine putois
gbowee sagna padilla pas de surprise on
est sur une france vous l'avez dit
aisées urbaines
âgées la france qui se sent bien dans la
mondialisation on en reparlera tout à
l'heure mais on a vraiment un découpage
du pays en trois grandes catégories on
on l'a vu lors des élections ça se
voyait même sur des cartons et ça se
retrouve dans les dents les ventilations
comme on dit des sondages ce qui est
intéressant avec ce niveau de 38 % de
popularité c'est un une baisse très
forte en l'espace d'un mois juste après
son élection
deux des comparaisons c'est à ça que
servent les baromètres finalement et les
comparaisons elles nous disent quoi
elles nous disent que emmanuel macron et
bien il sera resté quand même assez
longtemps à des niveaux de popularité
bien supérieure à cela lors de son
premier quinquennat les comparaisons
elles nous disent que finalement il est
déjà retombé à peu près dans l'étiage
moyens de sa popularité durant quand on
regarde les courbes à peu près les deux
dernières années donc un retour case
départ d'une certaine manière est dit
autrement on a un président qui se
trouve sous le seuil des 40 % skins qui
lie alors qu'il lui avait fallu un an et
demi lors de sa précédente élection sa
première élection pour passer sous cette
barre c'était en septembre 2018 après
laffaire benalla et si on remonte dans
le temps puisque on sait qu'en france on
déteste on adore brûler les présidents
qu'on a on vient d'élire les monarques
républicains si on remonte dans le temps
et qu'on compare à ses grands
prédécesseurs ses illustres
prédécesseurs et bien jacques chirac
après sa réélection il y avait eu des
cohabitations tout ça est différent mais
il avait mis trois ans à passer sous la
barre des 40 % et françois mitterrand en
81 trois ans aussi trois ans et demi
aussi après sa réélection donc pour un
président réélu mais sans passer par
l'espèce de phase ii virginité que
qu'octroie une cohabitation
paradoxalement et bien il se retrouve à
des niveaux de popularité
extraordinairement bas inédit très
empêcher après on pourra parler de
de sa première mission on parlera
d'elisabeth bornes juste après caire
chartier j'aimerais vous entendre sur
finalement ce ce potentiel de départ de
second mandat parce que c'est ça aussi
qui est intéressant dans dans le
baromètre avec quelle dose de confiance
et de popularité par emmanuel macron et
puis aussi je vous écoute est comparé à
jacques chirac et françois mitterrand on
était dans une autre époque de
communication et d'action présidentielle
beaucoup plus en retrait c'était une
partie de la solution pour emmanuel
macron sauf que c'est pas son c'est pas
sa pente naturelle ont annoncé lundi le
retrait de le pratiquer beaucoup quand
même beaucoup pratiqué voilà c'est ça
c'est à dire que c'est une question de
tempo est ce qui est assez étonnant ça
me faisait penser vous écoutant aux
images en fait de l'élection
présidentielle souvenez-vous lorsqu'il a
été élu c'était assez stupéfiant quand
même l'ambiance qui régnait c'était une
ambiance presque crépusculaire voilà
donc je trouve au champ de mars vraiment
c'était tout à fait curieux quand et de
ce fait je pense que les tendances à
serait de s'étonner en fait qu'il ne
soit plus haut que qui n'est aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est vraiment là la suite
logique de ce que l'on vit depuis ce
second tour des élections parce que en
fait il n'a rien changé il a continué à
une certaine manière commettre des
erreurs à mon sens par exemple son
intervention télévisée n'a absolument
rien apporté franchement pourquoi parler
certes on le précède intervenir
précisément de se manifester mais si
c'est pour se manifester de cette façon
là sans rien apporter et même ensemble
en revenir sur finalement la forme de
deux prises de conscience qu'ils avaient
manifesté que effectivement certains
avaient voté pour lui mais un peu par
défaut pour empêcher
marine le pen de passer enfin tout ça a
été quand même assez étonnant il ya eu
des cafouillages aussi sur et les filles
est ce que c'est un parti de digne
finalement de de coopération ou pas tout
ça finalement entretient la même chose
il ya absolument rien qui change il
n'est toujours pas présent est alors bon
à sa décharge il faut avouer que comme
il ne sait pas de quelle latitude va
disposer c'est vrai que c'est assez
difficile quand même d'avancer ses pions
là pour l'instant est là les médias sont
un peu responsable de ça parce qu'on
n'est tellement pas habituée en france à
cette fameuse façon d'exercer le pouvoir
bompard coalition enfin et paris par
discussions que du coup on en fait on
est extrêmement impatients et j'ai
évoqué la semaine dernière l'exemple
espagnol mais il est en fait y mettre
des semaines et voir des moins il est
partout et on parlera donc italiens et
allemands dans notre second débat et ça
ça peut même prendre des bien sûr quand
même des mois en allemagne c'est arrivé
pour pour former une coalition donc on
le pressent donc c'est vrai qu'à sa
décharge avait peut-être extrêmement
impatients nous aussi mais de toute
façon encore une fois il n'améliore
absolument pas son cas peut-on dire de
mais c'est quand même le paradoxe de ce
printemps
monsieur souquet ça va marquer notre
histoire politique en deux mois il est
passé du statut de seul président réélu
hors cohabitation à
président affaibli par la nouvelle donne
politique comment il peut réformer parce
que je pense que c'est son obsession de
second mandat comment il peut réformer
dans ces conditions en tout cas
effectivement il fait l'expérience et
nous faisons collectivement l'expérience
pour la première fois de cette situation
politique c'est le sortant qui est réélu
et c'est la majorité parlementaire
sortante qui est reconduite alors elle
est reconduite évidemment de façon moins
nette nous précédemment il ya quand même
une majorité dans la deuxième fois il ya
une majorité parlementaire la seule fois
où c'est arrivé en fait depuis giscard
c'est en 2007 en 2007 la majorité
parlementaire sortants de droite est
reconduite mais à la faveur de
l'élection de nicolas sarkozy qui se
marquent une rupture et c'est une forme
de rupture c'est la première fois qu'on
a et un pouvoir exécutif et un pouvoir
législatif qui sont reconduits et donc
nécessairement emmanuel macron et sa
majorité ont la longévité qui avait fait
défaut à tous leurs prédécesseurs sans
avoir pour autant la confiance et donc
l'élan qui va avec et donc la capacité
réformatrice qui tenait une place
importante dans la promesse initiale du
maquereau nisme il ya sans doute quand
même un élément d'explication
conjoncturelle alors il ya le fait
qu'ils se soient mis en retrait
l'opinion de ce point de vue là et elles
mêmes environ nival antar coque on
critique en permanence l'hyperprésidence
et de la raison ça nous est arrivé aux
six absolument et puis là effectivement
il fait un calcul différent de se mettre
en retrait alors pour partie ces du
calcul tactique pour partie il est un
peu dans les cordes donc il ya un peu
les deux mais en tout état cause on lui
reproche sa iliad usé qu'il ya du zig
zag politique qui à mon avis il paye
parce que encore une fois cette campagne
aura été un vaste exact politique elle
sait jouer à droite et même très à
droite au premier tour et puis on a
découvert l'écologie en 15 jours et
voilà on a changé de ligne politique on
démarre avec la retraite à 65 ans on
termine avec la planification écologique
et puis il ya le zig zag tactique quand
même qui fait qu'on dénonce d'abord à la
présidentielle le péril brin on dénonce
ensuite le péril rouge aux législatives
et à la fin on sait plus très bien selon
effectivement la vulgate macro nysc où
se situe le front républicain tout ça
sans doute se paye dans l'opinion
laetitia vous voulez revenir sur le la
communication du présent et vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement notamment 7
cette communication avec le choix de l'
agence france presse pour faire passer
ses messages samedi oui et ça illustre
exactement tout ce qu'on vient de dire
sur emmanuel macron c'est à dire qu'il
nous avait promis rappelez vous une
méthode nouvelle soir de sa réélection à
la tente toujours parce que là il
continue de faire du en même temps il
n'est pas en france vous savez que l'a
aidé dans cette séquence à
l'international au g7 aujourd'hui en
partance pour madrid pour l'otan il
était à bruxelles et pourtant il
continue de parler aux français ils
continuent de d'alimenter finalement le
débat national et donc samedi soir parce
que ce n'est pas samedi samedi soir
après avoir rencontré on a appris après
elisabeth bornes longtemps à l'elysée
tombe sur nos écrans je pense que tout
le monde a été mis sous fait accompli
les déclarations d' emmanuel macron et
pas des moindres parce que si vous avez
raison claire de dire que finalement son
intervention télévisée a été plutôt vide
de déclaration là on apprend quand même
des décisions qui sont fondamentales
c'est à dire qu'il maintient elisabeth
bornes etc il exclue du jeu politique
donc elle est fille et le rn et tout ça
se passe via l' agence france-presse
donc qui ensuite envoie aux rédactions 1
les déclarations d' emmanuel macron
c'est pas une interview non il n'y a pas
de questionnements journalistique
pourquoi excluez-vous elle est fille ou
arn du jeu politique est ce que ce sont
des partis républicains on enfin bon
bref on imagine toutes les questions qui
auraient pu avoir et donc emmanuel
macron a deux objectifs continuer à être
et à rester le maître des horloges vous
savez qu'il déteste qu'on lui impose un
agenda donc là c'est lui qui choisit
samedi soir d'envoyer directement de ses
nouvelles aux français via les médias et
aussi un peu contrecarré les critiques
qu'on avait fait de lui il abandonne le
pays alors qu on est en pleines
négociations pour une coalition et lui
dit non je n'ai pas abandonné le pays
puisque je continue encore une fois vous
donner des nouvelles et aujourd'hui il
continue sur voilà là même la même
méthode c'est à dire qu'ils les derniers
jours du g7 en allemagne dernière
question de la conférence de presse ce
midi qui porte sur cette recherche de
coalitions de consensus et sur damien
abad restera restera t-il pas au
gouvernement emmanuel macron bas d'un
revers de main en disant écoutez j'ai
une règle je ne réponds pas à des
questions intérieures quand je suis à
l'extérieur et quand même il y répond
crise de pouvoir d'achat que nous vivons
elle n'a pas le coeur de sa réponse au
niveau national coeur de sa réponse dans
le travail que nous faisons sur le plan
international j'insiste sur ce point
c'est pourquoi ces sommets du g7 qui
peuvent parfois elle semblait très
lointain nos compatriotes très
désincarné touche en fait des sujets qui
sont essentiels pour notre quotidien
parce qu'on parle de plein de courses et
du plein d'essence évidemment il ne
répond pas sur damien abad
mais il explique que le g7 est important
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français et
donc explique pourquoi il est au g7 et
il explique encore une fois qu'il a un
pied dehors un pied dedans un pied en
france et un pied à l'extérieur le
domaine réservé du président de la
république reste l'international mais il
ne veut absolument pas lâcher les
manettes du national alors on va parler
d isabey devant tout de suite et
j'accueille avec nous en duplex benjamin
grange qui est prêt dans la société
mascaret qui qui participe évidemment
avec vous à ce baromètre pour analyser
les mouvements d'opinion sur les réseaux
sociaux les médias sociaux
benjamin grange si on regarde la
popularité d'isabey de bornes 33%
d'opinions favorables - 10 points et
comment est-ce qu'elle imprime un petit
peu vous voyez un jeu super ambitieux
sur les réseaux sociaux
ont fêté les abbés de bornes elle a
imprimé au moment de sa nomination s'est
posé la question qui était elizabeth
porn son attitude le dossier sous le
bras sont des choses qui ont beaucoup
fait parler sur les réseaux et puis très
vite 7 comment dire ce moment elisabeth
borne n'a pas été renouvelé depuis ce
l'élection de la nouvelle assemblée est
finalement là où elle aurait pu revenir
avec une forme de peut-être de projets
ou de deux discours de politique
générale très très très ambitieux et
bien finalement elle a été
elle a été esquivée par l'ensemble des
affaires au tour de damien abad de de
crise où la cour aux poules uci
halderman qui finalement aucune
terriblement en fait les esprits et je
dirais que les internautes finissent par
ne parlait que de ça au lieu de parler
du thé lisabeth bornes wii mais
d'ailleurs c'est une des leçons de la la
campagne aussi chris lye mal finalement
de quoi on a parlé dans les dernières
semaines de la campagne législative
effectivement damien abad et puis du
fiasco du stade de france je sais pas si
vous l'avez mesure est là mais est ce
qu'on sait si par exemple cette histoire
du fiasco du stade de france a fait
perdre beaucoup de voix à la majorité
présidentielle ou est ce que finalement
c'est quasi impossible de répondre à
cette question alors mis les deux mon
général on a on a testé c'est difficile
de pouvoir quantifier le nombre de
points perdus en revanche pour illustrer
ce que disait benjamin sur elisabeth
bornes et et pour répondre à votre
question on a dans un sondage
hebdomadaire qu'on fait régulièrement
sur l'actualité avec le figaro on a posé
ses questions sur l'impact qu'avait eu
ces événements stade de france et damien
abad sur votre vote c'était juste avant
les législatives et on avait une
proportion de l'ordre de 30% des
électeurs des français les gars qui nous
disait ça comptera dans mon vote alors
relativisons parce que beaucoup de ces
30% étaient déjà des gens qui voulaient
voter pour la nuit baisse ou pour le rn
donc ça n'a fait qu'en réalité les
conforter dans leur choix mais ça a sans
doute joué parce que je rebouc juste
d'un mot sur ce qu'on disait sur
ce que vous disiez vous avez je pense
tout à fait raison sur le timing de
d'emmanuel macro on ne peut pas dire les
français les commentateurs les acteurs
disent tout et son contraire au prétexte
qu'il trouvait emmanuel macron trop
présent et puis à certains moments moins
présent c'est juste que ce n'est pas au
bon moment qu'il est peut pas assez
présents ont trop présent en
l'occurrence là on l'a mesuré pour
l'avant législatives et même pour la fin
la présidentielle il s'est mis dans une
nasse en envoyant comme seul signal
politique audible pour les gens la
retraite à 65 ans vous l'évoquez tout à
l'heure les gens ont retenu ça et sans
doute qu'il a perdu des points au
premier un petit peu et beaucoup au
second tour --qu'il a perdu la majorité
aux législatives parce qu'il a posé ce
pavé dans la mare et que les seules
choses qui ont été audible pour les
électeurs des de la présidentielle et
des législatives
en dehors de cette question de la
retraite à 65 ans eh bien ce sont des
scories d affaires d des scandales
médiatiques quant à elisabeth bornes
j'allais dire sans condescendance la
pauvre elisabeth bande parce que dans
les enquêtes les gens vous avez vu la
courbe de mascaret sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux les gens ne pensent pas
de mal intrinsèquement d'elisabeth
bornes la nomination d'une femme
première ministre était attendu et
souhaité par les français simplement ils
estiment les français c'est encore un
sondage que nous avons résilié qu'il ya
quelques jours qu elle de qu'elle aurait
dû démissionner ou qu'il aurait dû
demander à la première ministre de
démissionner pas contre elle mais pour
signifier politiquement qu'il tenait
compte du résultat de ces législatives
et proposer un changement de grande
ampleur et c'est sans doute pour cela
oui et c'est mais c'est pour ça c'est
pour cela qu'elle baisse de 10 points ce
mois-ci et alors ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle ne remontera pas l'avenir mais
c'est quand même violent parce que
jamais son prédécesseur jean castex
n'avait été sous la barre des 34 % et
jamais edouard philippe ne l'avait été
non plus alors c'est intéressant ce
qu'on hésite parce que justement là la
comparaison
d'elisabeth morne avec ses prédécesseurs
c'est ce que proposait ce matin le
milieu intérieur gérald darmanin il
était sur rtl en disant que grosso modo
elle subit les mêmes critiques que
loire philippe ou jean castex écoutez il
appartient la première ministre qui a
pas un métier facile qui est très
courageuse moi je la vois travailler
depuis plusieurs semaines désormais de
former un gouvernement faisant plus
confiance elle est légitime elisabeth
ben évidemment d'abord elle a été élu
dans des conditions très difficiles dans
le calvados et je peux vous assurer
qu'elle est passé politique vous savez
c'est rigolo parce que il ya cinq ans je
veux pas vous vos collègues m'avaient
dit vos confrères est ce que doit
philippe est légitime est ce qu'il est
assez politique il était pas député il
venait du havre est un peu techno ça a
été un grand premier ministre puis après
on m'a dit est ce que jean castex quand
j'ai été nommé à l'intérieur étaient
légitimes n'hésitez pas et lui était un
peu techno et c'est un grand premier
ministre haydon sera une grande première
ministre claire charti est-ce qu'on
enterre pas un peu vite je mette plein
de limay en terre
je pense qu'il ya pas mal de choses à
dire je voudrais juste revenir sur
l'élément il aurait dû finalement
accepter sa démission il ensuite je pas
certaine que les français soient très
attentifs à ça très honnêtement bien peu
de gens mon avis qu'ils savent qu'un oui
mais il ya peut-être des gens qui savent
véritablement quel est le mécanisme qui
veut de sable je pense à ce que lisent
et on passe dans la rue on voit tous les
titres même si on n'achète pas les
journaux car aux catastrophes impasse ah
oui mais la mécanique institut mai mais
des gens qui sont à l'opinion publique
et quand même et quand même impacté par
la couverture médiatique et quand on a
compté les médias c'était que ça s'était
dit là où on se dit c'est pas quelques
ne pas accepter sa démission en gros
qu'elle s'en aille qu'elle quitte
matignon le la mécanique non pas pour la
reprendre d'accord pour ne pas la
ressentir alors je vais vous laisser
conclure je vais mettre mon grain de sel
je pense que ça aurait été dévastateur
sur emmanuel macron s'il peut y avoir
des français qui disent avant ben oui
elle aurait dû partir parce que tenir
compte du résultat des élections mais
qui après on aurait dit mais c'est une
honte comment il l'a laissé en place
pendant un mois et demi alors qu'elle
est là mon point de vue elle est donc
restée je pense que
son problème à elisabeth bande c'est que
en fait comme vous le disiez elle
incarne un peu la technocratie le saint
simonisme d'emmanuel macron et le
problème c'est que précisément emmanuel
macron durant cette campagne à la fois
présidentielle et législatives on ne
savait pas quel était son programme donc
c'est une sorte de comment dire
ça manque de contour en quelque sorte et
le technocrate la figure du technocrate
manque de contour c'est quelque chose de
très technique non c'est pas trop ce
qu'on met dedans et en fait elle renvoie
à ça à cette forme d'indécision
accroc niel c'est à dire que nous on
sait pas où on en est et donc on nous
met une experte mais une experte de
coiffes à tout ça reste assez font ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est que je pense quand même il faut
bien le dire et quand on regarde marine
le pen ça se voit que la façon d'être ce
qu'on dégage a une importance en
politique et malheureusement et bien
alors peut-être est-ce parce que
précisément elle est très techno et
c'est à elle ne dégage pas à proprement
parler quelque chose de trek qui donne
envie d'aller de l'avant et c'est alain
elle emmène pas les gens marine le pen
elle a beaucoup travaillé là dessus elle
son problème c'était pas qu'elle
emmenait pas les gens c'est qu'elle
était agressive elle a beaucoup
travaillé et ça a vraiment porté ses
fruits donc ça c'est un autre aspect
d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué je ne sais pas
si vous l'avez vu mais elle est beaucoup
plus souriante que il ya quelques jours
à peut-être parce qu'elle a été
confirmée mais n'empêche que je pense
qu'elle a travaillé sa façon d'être
devant les caméras sas et je pense que
c'est pas mal parce qu en démocratie et
surtout dans leur haine de l'image qui
est le nôtre c'est très important et
dernier petit point comme vous le
soulignez tout à l'heure c'est que la
pauvre ça finalement sa confirmation
elle est passée comme ça par la sp alors
que le fameux discours de madame macron
qu'il a eue qu'il a prononcé à la
télévision là il aurait pu dire quand
même il aurait pu parler d'elle ne l'a
même pas citer la même pas citer donc la
pompe en plus elle est même éclipsé par
son dos c'est vrai mais je repose un peu
la même question est ce qu'elle peut
nous surprendre c'est une autre façon de
dire 'est-ce qu'on n'enterre pas un peu
trop vite à ce stade en tout cas c'est
le contexte qui nous surprend et et et
elle est le président de la république
subissent le contexte je rebondis sur ce
que vous dites en fait il est vrai qu'
elle n'est pas aidée par son patron en
lités d'abord on a compris le départ est
ce qu'il a un tout petit peu plombé
quand même qu'elle n'était pas le
premier choix du président de la
république en tout cas le microcosme a
bien compris que c'était catherine
vautrin qui devait être nommé premier
ministre et que elisabeth bande n'était
qu'un plan b et puis effectivement
derrière alors on a vendu le profil
d'une super techno elle même d'ailleurs
a fait son auto promotion en disant moi
c'est l'efficacité la promesse
d'efficacité du maquereau nisme je vais
non seulement la prolonger mais je vais
l'amplifier or manque de pot elles se
heurtent dès ses premiers jours à la
sphère abad à la sphère du stade de
france pas on n'a pas vu un pouvoir
exécutif en fait mes gammes
professionnelles donc du coup la
promesse initiale était aussi un peu
plombé et comme vous le disiez en fait à
l'instant derrière emmanuel macron à
gérer le timing et à gérer la
communication de façon tout à fait
étonnante vis-à-vis d'elle il prend la
parole sans la citer et sans doute parce
qu'à ce moment là elle est
potentiellement c'est un siège éjectable
on ne sait pas et d'ailleurs au moment
où elle lui présente sa démission il ne
dit pas qu'il accepte pour l'art
confirmé il dit précisément il refuse sa
démission est en gros on va voir en
quelques jours donc pour fragiliser
quand même ça ça sa première ministre on
fait difficilement mieux voilà alors
ensuite on va voir encore une fois calé
pour de vrai sa feuille de route on
comprend qu'un profil techno pouvait
avoir ses vertus et en fait le contexte
dit plutôt le contraire elle travaille
quand même à ce profil techno parce que
elle a donné une interview à paris match
une interview à lci avec exactement la
même teneur briser l'armure c'était la
semaine dernière le même aux roses vous
remarquerez el hadj salah el alami le
même au rose bonbon rose a une couleur
on va pas faire et si la sémiologie mais
bon ça ça tootoo a son importance et
elle revient sur son enfance difficile
le suicide de son père donc évidemment
elle fait aussi cet exercice là
d'aller vers son intimité en tout cas de
l'offrir aux français pour gagner en
popularité parce qu'elle serait
davantage moi la plus proche des
français mais ça c'est un pari qui se
fait sur du long terme et on le disait
dans le sujet gaël sliman le baromètre
c'est juste avant qu'elle soit confirmée
je sais pas ça aurait tout changé grand
chose mais bon non je pense probablement
probablement rien il est pour et pour
vous répondre et
ne pas faire injure à l'avenir
concernant elisabeth bornes quand on
regarde les courbes de popularité elle
part de plus bas très vite que ses deux
prédécesseurs et que la plupart de ses
prédécesseurs d'ailleurs mais quand vous
regardez la courbe de popularité
d'edouard philippe edouard philippe
d'ailleurs je dis une bêtise il est
tombé une fois à 31% donc plus bas
qu'elle aujourd'hui ni jamais en fait il
ya eu une fois où il est tombé plus bas
et à la fin de l'année 2018 au début
2009 exactement et finalement il s'est
révélé au français
partagent pas tout à fait ce que disait
le ministre arménien il ya un instant
dans votre extrait mais il ya une vérité
c'est que les gens peuvent découvrir
aussi des politiques et edouard philippe
il est devenu depuis quelques années
c'est encore le cas ce mois ci la
personnalité politique préférée des
français quand il était en paix très
dans les différentes crises que qu'on
évoquait type gilet jaune ou 80
kilomètres heure qu'il était au plus bas
dans les sondages on n'aurait peut-être
pas imaginé que très peu de temps après
en quittant matignon il deviendrait de
l'abbé pierre à une odieuse et
démissionner il n'a pas démissionné elle
s'est fait gentiment viré et puis plus
haut mais est élevé et escarpée ce qui
arrive alvin qu'ils en tirent les
profits donc on verra bien c'est vrai
que la période politique est très
compliqué si elisabeth board en sortira
finalement sur la dans les deux mois qui
viennent un deux trois textes où elle
réussit à construire une majorité
relative qui permet aux textes beauté
peut-être qu'on dira d'autres d'autres
choses sur ce sur ce plateau et salisien
quand même comme ça il y aurait pas de
malédiction aux féminines parce qu'on
est mal partie là c'est quand même la
deuxième et première ça se présente mal
donc pitié et ça a certainement joué
dans la décision oui il faudrait
qu'elles réussissent à garder ce que si
ben jama grand je voulais intervenir je
donne ma parole
oui non je voulais simplement compléter
les propos il ya un contexte aussi qui
est pas du tout propice à les abbés de
bornes c'est que avec cette volonté des
français de d'avoir cette opposition
parlementaire ça a mis un coup de
projecteur sur jean luc mélenchon est
évidemment sur comment dire tous les
lits tous les leaders derrière les
quatre menaces les bons par les bardes
et l'un du côté est reine qui explosent
en fait sur les réseaux parce que en
fait le relais français leur posent des
questions et se posent des questions sur
leur nouveau poids politique donc donc
que ça associé au fait que les nerfs
devienne une clé politique pour
l'opposition comme pour la majorité
finalement on se retrouve dans un dans
un contexte où quand on n'a pas de
grandes annonces à faire c'est très
compliqué pour les habs bornes d'exister
en fait dans les conversations des
français est sain ce serait un point qui
sera très compliqué derrière eux à
remonter alors vous m'offrez la
transition puisque on va maintenant
parler d'un autre enseignement de ce
baromètre au doxa mascaret et j'appelle
quentin calme et à nous rejoindre dans
soir quand un bienvenue le rn et la
nuque grand gagnant de ce mois c'est
exactement l'expression effectivement
utilisés dans cette étude de doxa pour
public sénat lcp et la presse régionale
commençons par le rassemblement national
4 français sur 10 disent en juin 2022
avoir une bonne opinion du rn et c'est
surtout la dynamique 1 et qui
impressionne les sondeurs note la forte
évolution c'est 40 % de bonnes
intentions elles sont au plus haut le
parti n'avait que 12 % d'opinions
favorables en 2011 c'est-à-dire quand
marine le pen prend la présidence du
rassemblement national à l'époque front
national las nubes dispose également
d'un bon score de popularité avec 36%
d'opinions favorables des scores qu'il
faut immédiatement nuancé car n'eut peu
nu pc et rn font peur à une majorité de
français déjà ces deux formations
politiques sont qualifiés d'extrêmes par
six français sur dix à gauche et à
droite le rn et d'extrême droite oui à
64 % disent les français interrogés la
nuque et extrême gauche oui à la 58 % la
nuque élus et rennes peuvent amener le
désordre on le voit la nuque et le rn
également ont un programme dangereux
pour notre économie enfin un français
sur deux thomas pensent que ces partis
ou coalitions sont des dangers pour la
démocratie
dernière information que je voulais vous
apporter sur ces deux formations ou
parti politique c'est un petit focus sur
et bien le profil de leurs électeurs
type commençons par la nuque elle est
particulièrement représentée auprès des
jeunes un électeur de 18-24 ans sur deux
a voté pour cette coalition en miroir
les lecteurs du r'n et mieux
représentées en milieu rural et chez des
quinquas ce qui fait écrire
effectivement à odos que ça cette
conclusion que je voulais vous lire avec
impayés fracturé en trois blocs
politiques et sociologiques totalement
antinomique 3 france qui cohabitent le
centre macro nist soutenu par des
classes urbaines aisées et les retraités
sur sa gauche la nuque urbaine jeunes et
pauvres bien que souvent diplômés et sur
sa droite le rn qui rassemble davantage
les pauvres plus âgés en zones rurales
et périurbaines thomas merci quentin je
viens vers vous mathieu soupière parce
que en préparant les missions vous
disiez mais le fait majeur de
de cette séquence politique que les
temps en est en train de vivre c'est le
rassemblement national oui enfin qui a
atteint mais encore une fois en fait ce
n'est pas une surprise c'est juste que
les instituts de sondage gis je me fais
évidemment le procès de personnes ont eu
du mal à traduire en projection en
sièges effectivement le score présumé en
fait du gras sont essentielles dans le
dans dans l'opinion en fait marine le
pen a gagné les quatre tours cerqual a
fait un score très élevé au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle ait atteint
un niveau inédit au deuxième tour et
puis en réalité l'extrême droite et la
mouvance politique qui a le mieux
performé aux élections législatives et
encore une fois on n'avait pas vu venir
et papa elle d'ailleurs enfin il y
compris marine le pen on n'avait pas vu
venir qu' il allait tangente et avec la
centaine de députés et ça pour le coup
oui c'est en fait c'est un séisme majeur
hors jeu rebondit sur ce qu'on se disait
il y a une il ya une société française
archi p10 et la société française en
archipel on la retrouve au parlement il
ya un parlement archipel ise avec trois
blocs tout à fait irréconciliables mais
celui qui domine celui qui tire son
épingle du jeu y compris dans le récit
médiatique c'est bien l'extrême droite
l'extrême droite en réalité n'a jamais
investi le champ parlementaire pour
faire de la politique et je dirais même
que ce soit à l'assemblée nationale ou
même au parlement européen où on sait
que le parti de marine le pen traîne
quelques casseroles ce que manifestement
les assistants parlementaires ont pu
servir à autre chose que de préparer des
délibérations au sein du parlement de
strasbourg donc ils n'ont jamais investi
en fait le champ parlementaires ils ont
fait de la politique autrement
comparativement à la france a soumises
qui pendant cinq ans avec 17 députés à
1000 da aura à l'assemblée et à gérer a
pour partie rythmée en fait l'agenda
politique le ratio l'ancien n'a jamais
fait ça là pour le coup avec 90 députés
précisément ils vont investir le travail
parlementaire ils vont gagner en
crédibilité en respectabilité ils vont
se donner du ils vont se doter d'une
force de deux députés de représentants
politiques et de collaborateurs
politiques comme ils n'en auront jamais
eu entre 300 et 400 collaborateurs il va
falloir les recruter il va falloir
former mais une fois qu'ils seront là ce
sera pour le coup une armée de gens
extrêmement actif et potentiellement
compétents donc les cinq années qui
s'ouvre vont être pour l'heure asocial
le précisément une option extrêmement
favorable pour gagner en poids et en
puissance politique c'est une petite
question à haga estevan pour vous pondre
mathieu serait ce que parce qu'il me
semble quand même que parmi les
électeurs je ne parle pas des cas là les
électeurs de la france a soumises et du
rassemblement national il ya une petite
zone grise où on quand même pas ce que
vous nous dites que ce sont deux blocs
voilà huit ans un peu de porosité que
voisin charles oui il me semble quand
même et quand on regarde l'électorat ça
fait partie de cette france en colère
qui est en colère contre le système on
va dire voilà pour caricaturer mais il
ya quand même une zone une zone fois
c'est ce que jean luc mélenchon
finalement résume en disant les met face
à face et où il a lâché dans les fâcher
pas facho c'est ça oui oui fâché mais
on sait que vous avez tous les deux
raison et ça se rejoint c'est à dire que
on souligne jeu on souligne dans
l'exposé qui étaient faits s'était
rappelée une france fracture et
archipels is et pour paraphraser un de
mes confrères jérôme fourquet mais quand
même c'est un archipel avec des grandes
tendances qu'on requis se recoupent donc
on a bien ces trois blocs mais c'est pas
pour eux et ça fait le lien avec ce que
ce que vous disiez sur le fait qu' on
n'a pas vu venir le rassemblement
national en gros en fourchette haute on
approchait la cinquantaine dans les
projections et et encore on devait nous
on avait ça et on va être ce qui les
aide dont le plus haut et ils font le
double et pourquoi exactement pour la
raison que vous évoquez et c'est à dire
que dans les sondages les gens nous
disaient on ne veut plus du front
républicain c'est hors de question
traduction dans les matrices de
projections en sièges c'est un peu
technique mais en gros pas de bonus de
front républicain chose incroyable déjà
ça vaudra pas plus quand il ya un duel
nubes et rennes on estimait qu'électeur
ensemble ne voterai pas plus pour la
nuit parce que pour le rn
pas de bol si j'ose dire ça a été même
encore au delà et ça signifie qu'en fait
quand vous aviez alors c'est ce que vous
évoquez des duels entre
ensemble et le rnr eh bien les électeurs
nubes vote est substantiel non seulement
il n'était pas plus pour les candidats
républicains entre guillemets mais ils
votaient même substantiellement plus
pour le n et quand on a des questions
croisées sur des du vote de premier tour
du vote de second tour du second choix
de vote eh bien oui ça existe la fameuse
théorie du fer à cheval qui était
développé et quelques années à sciences
po utilisaient les extrêmes sur jeunes
s'étaient largement fosse à l'époque
faire que ça existait mais comme le
poisson volant c'était très marginale
aujourd'hui ça existe de façon beaucoup
plus nette sur la possibilité de voter
pour le fn pour 1 us plus tôt pour
ensemble ou varier du simple au double
donc c'est assez important si on regarde
les côtes d'adhésion de jean-luc
mélenchon et de marine le pen la cote
d'adhésion de du fondateur de la france
est soumise à l'état 28% 63% pour les
sympathisants de gauche et d'extrême
gauche et puis si on regarde donc ça
c'est pour jean luc mélenchon et ensuite
si on voit celle de marine le pen sa
cote d'adhésion est plus élevée elle est
à 36 % de code d'adhésion avec 78% pour
les sympathisants de droite et extrême
race et surtout qu'ils sont deuxième et
troisième de nos codes d'adhésion des
personnalités c'est lui qui sont
derrière le champion toute catégorie
edouard philippe il ya bruno le maire
qui est au coude à coude avec jean luc
mélenchon mais c'est très très haut et
ils font la loi dans leur camp et ses
sympathisants de gauche toute la gauche
c'est ça et sympathisants de droite
toute la droite qui en incluant les
élèves elle arrive mais il ya beaucoup
de et rennes aussi donc elle arrive en
tête c'est ça qui est frappant je
reviens sur le finalement le
stade ultime de la banalisation du
rassemblement national avec ses deux
populaires et vous avez vu avec la
progression x 4 en l'espace de quelques
années oui effectivement on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure donc je suis sur cette
banalisation mathieu soutient
effectivement le fait d'entrer comme ça
renforce 89 députés à l'assemblée de
bénéficier des structures de de
l'assemblée bon ça va faire des petits
si j'ose dire dans les années à venir il
ya eu une première image aujourd'hui
claire chartier qui est l image du doyen
de l'assemblée qui présidait la séance
d'ouverture qui est un député du
rassemblement national c'était déjà
arrivé une fois mais quand même quayola
un symbole qui est assez fortement comme
comme le disait mathieu et même quand on
pense à jean marie le pen jean-marie le
pen jamais eu véritablement la volonté à
d'exercer le pouvoir c'était vraiment
pour mettre le bazar est vraiment
incarné une opposition vraiment mais
c'était pas du tout la même idée là on
est dans une autre époque un
véritablement n'a changé de c'est à mon
avis ce qui explique que finalement
la tactique de marine le pen qui a été
celle quand même d'atténuer un son son
message qu'on en fait on a on a beaucoup
dit dans un temps précédent que ça
pouvait la desservir parce que ça allait
tiédir son propos est du coup lui
aliéner les anti système parce que
souvenez vous c'était quand même pas à
la lime on se demande même on ne se
souvient même plus que c'était un parti
anti système en fait qui disait l'état
rpr enfin pour ne citer que cet exemple
donc on se disait ça va desservir marine
le pen en fait ça ne l'a pas desservi et
aujourd'hui cet argument effectivement
ne tient plus pourquoi parce que elle
peut elle le fait elle parle de
compromis elle parle de responsabilité
enfin c'est une figure qui incarne la
voilà le sens de la responsabilité et
j'en viendrais à cette idée d'
extrêmement intéressante parce que c'est
un problème d'un point de vue sémantique
quelqu'un qui incarne ça et qui est
entendu pour ce message-là de on va agir
en responsabilité c'est qu'il ya
aujourd'hui donc des représentants qui
ont des idées des fonctions
institutionnelles c'est quand même
difficile de qualifier ce parti
d'extrémistes ça devient compliqué en
fait et ça ne la dessert pas en fait
parce que effectivement aujourd'hui est
bien la possibilité du pouvoir en tout
cas du poids relatif elle est là je
pense qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant dans ces sondages c'est
que d'un côté on dit ces partis font
peur et puis de l'autre vous avez des
résultats tout à fait surprenants sur la
populaire popularité de ses personnages
donc je reviens assez à mon avis ce
paradoxe ça je pense qu'on a bien aidés
il ya une confusion sémantique autour de
la notion d' extrême je pense que ça
décès en fait l'objectif de ceux qui
veulent pointer les extrémismes quand on
parle d'extrême gauche pour elle est
fille je pense que c'est une erreur
l'extrême gauche c'est un projet
révolutionnaire le on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon
lorsqu'il dit qu'ils veulent il refuse
le chantage été regardé son programme
refuser le chantage de la dette publique
- réduction du temps de travail revenir
sur toutes les privatisations est allé
même jusqu'à déclencher une commission
parlementaire pour mettre en examen ce
qui aurait privatiser les fleurons et
c'est un bon on peut trouver ça
détestable le retour de l'esprit
robespierre mais c'est pas la révolution
donc ses rivales la première image sur
à l'assemblée c'est quand même le point
le poing levé ça fait par casser la tête
un peu le symbole de la région mais
attendez l'extrême gauche se revendique
du
progrès c'est le capitalisme donc ça
n'est pas d'extrême gauche de l'autre
côté on a une véritablement une extrême
droite mais qui devient dans l'opinion
publique pas du tout extrême part en
raison de l'habileté de marine le pen
mais pourtant quand on regarde dans le
détail elle remet en question
effectivement notre conception de l'état
de droit elle remet en question des
principes qui était le socle de 1789 et
ensuite de la delà de la constitution de
1958 avec son idée de référendum sur
l'immigration et avec son idée de
priorité nationale donc ça ce sont des
choses très profondes qui vraiment
caractérise l'extrême droite donc c'est
vraiment très paradoxal et en utilisant
mal à mon avis les concepts on introduit
une confusion qui fait qu'on peut dire
d'un côté olala on a peur de ces parties
là et puis de l'autre en fait de voter
pour eux et finalement de les délits
célébrée dans le palmarès des
personnalités
j'ai une petite question encore une fois
et je vais tourner vers ma soupe hier
d'un bep parce que j'ai la réponse mais
est ce que on n'assiste pas au phénomène
populiste je parle de police puisque
vous avez écrit un ouvrage sur voilà ce
phénomène là que qui est arrivé aux
etats-unis avec donald trump avec un
programme d'extrême droite il a été élu
en italie bien avant donald trump et les
extrêmes droites est encore dans la
coalition italienne avec un taux de
popularité record 58 % donc tout le
monde accepte en allemagne l'allemagne
aussi à dans sa commission l'afd qui est
extrême droite dans son programme au
brésil en fête se passe au maroc
[Rires]
louis est donc marine le pen c'est
l'exemple sauf que
sauf qu'elle n'est pas au pouvoir mais
c'est un mouvement qui
l'ont de lunatic mais les deux
mouvements ont pu surfer avec des
calendriers différents sur une
rhétorique anti système sauf que là
effectivement on n'en est plus là ils
sont désormais en train d'entrer dans le
système puisqu'ils représentent les deux
forces d'opposition principal au au
parlement absolument la majorité
présidentielle pardon est un mineur la
majorité présidentielle a entretenu la
confusion dont claire par l'est en
réalité encore une fois quand on renvoie
les extrêmes en permanence deux ados
qu'on explique que c'est la même menace
en réalité précisément on entretient
cette confusion dans l'opinion voilà et
une information privée est élu donc au
perchoir ça tombe à l'instant et on
pourra le commenter dans notre second
débat merci à tous d'avoir participé à
ce sens publiées